joël joël papa papa regarde je vois joël
jouer je vais j'ai trouvé un nouveau
truc quand je suis pas bien sûr que ce
que je vois est réel et ça m'aide à voir
la différence est une façon originale de
combattre la schizophrénie hier soir
chez jouait chez qui je fais du
baby-sitting s'est passé une chose
étrange personne
j'ai senti comme une pré sence
ce que les schizophrènes ont tous les
mêmes visions il est temps de parler
maintenant
si les primes en quelques vous soyez
capable par vous même d'identifier ce
qui est réel ou non besoin d'être prêt
pour l'exercice des livres du temps tout
se passe dans votre tête vous devez
arrêter tout ça
écoutez moi bien mon garçon le théme ans
peut transformer la farine en sachet et
transformer la science en folie